listen I love Face-Off I mean I love
Face-Off and I know that there's been
talk for a while Adam Wingard but maybe
doing a sequel is that actually going to
happen is that something that interests
you oh yeah I know I love face off too
and I think Face-Off is a sequel that
lends itself to a lot of uh twists and
turns and unpredictability it's it's
almost like uh if you factor in the idea
of
Offspring and and Castor and Sean having
children and these children grow up then
it becomes like three-dimensional chess
and what's then it's not just the two
John Travolta and myself it's four of us
ping-ponging and going at different
levels and it becomes even more complex
I think there's a lot of
fertile ground there
um I had maybe one meeting uh in an
office but I haven't heard anything
since so I don't know I really if Adam
is directing I really want it to happen
uh me too he's great and I I think we
should share similar tastes we have
similar sensibilities I liked everything
he did with Godzilla and Kong and I I
think that he's smart you know he has
respect for cinnamon and various kinds
of iconography so I think it would be
great